merci merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer monsieur le ministre ce matin
vous avez ordonné l'évacuation du
campement du crack situé dans le square
forceval à Paris le prolongement de la
colline du crack cette colline de
l'enfer annonçait comme une opération
d'envergure dans la lutte contre la
drogue dans la capitale une question
demeure monsieur le ministre où sont-ils
allés où vont-ils aller seront-ils
soignés les opérations de ces dernières
années ont montré que les consommateurs
et leur dealer changer d'endroit
rapidement souvent d'ailleurs peu de
temps avant le passage des forces de
l'ordre cette situation reste un drame
humain considérable pour ces centaines
de personnes qui se droguent sous nos
yeux associe s'ajoutent des scènes d'une
violence inouïe qui se déroule tous les
jours dans la capitale comme par exemple
l'agression d'un bébé de policiers d'un
pharmacien d'une opticienne d'une femme
poussée sur les rails du métro et sans
oublier tout dernièrement l'agression
extrêmement violente d'un homme de 92
ans roux et de coup par une toxicomane à
Paris c'est une évidence le plan craque
est un échec le problème n'est pas
traité juste déplacé du 19e au 18e
arrondissement ou inversement alors
monsieur le ministre que comptez-vous
faire pour éradiquer
définitivement le trafic et la
consommation du crack à Paris